so uh welcome to the final session of
today uh our speaker is James uh now at
mitability of the station the amount of
difference
thanks for the introduction uh so this
topic is about in distinguished video
application
where mathematical proof of equivalence
this worker is joined with abstractions
so what is the program application so
the indistinguishability association is
an algorithm that takes the source code
of some program as input and output of
schedule program that looks
unintelligible
and we also want to obscale the program
to preserve the functionality of the
input program so that means for every
input to the observation program it
should produce the same output as the
original program
another security of IO is defined as the
following indistinguishability security
so it can be viewed as a game between an
adversary and a challenger so this
Challenger will try to decide whether
this adversaries attack for Io is
success is successful or not
so initially there are those three
chooses two circuits or two programs c0
and C1 and send them to the
send them to this Challenger
and the Challenger will randomly flip a
coin B and also create one of the two
programs and the center of scheduler
program back to this anniversary
and the start over 3 is required to
guess which program is on stated
so there are those really sends back the
guessing bit D Prime to this Challenger
in the end the Challenger will verify
whether the two programs c0 and C1 are
functionality equivalent so
functionality equivalence means that for
every input X c0fx will output C has the
same output as C1 of x
so the Challenger also checks whether B
Prime equals B and if both tracking
passes then this Challenger declare list
of this adversary wins the game
so the security of IO requires that the
probability for any adversary wins the
game is bounded by half plus some
negligible function
so intuitively so if the adversary
randomly tests the speed the speed B
Prime the interval win this game with
probability no more than half so
intuitively this indistinguishability
security requires that for any
anniversary its ability to distinguish
the observative programs of c0 and C1
cannot be much better than our random
guessing
and here I want to emphasize this in
this security definition it's important
to check the functional the
functionality equivalence of c0 and C1
because if c0 and C1 differs at the same
input point x0 then the adversary can
certainly distinguish the obscale
programs of c0 and C1 by running the
obscillator program at this point x0 and
observe its output
so previously IO is a very important
topic it is sometimes called
cryptographic complete problem because
if you know how to build i o then you
can use it to achieve many other
cryptographic tasks so they include
Advanced encryption schemes or some
succinct cryptographic proof systems it
also has applications in complexity
Theory such as the hardware Supernatural
equilibrium
so IO is very useful so can we build
them so this question has been studied
for quite a long time and recently by
the Breakthrough work by James and sahi
they show how to build i o for General
circuits from well-founded assumptions
so in this work we study the following
questions can we build i o for Turing
machines
so why we care about the Turing machines
why isn't isn't the circular model good
enough
so the first reason is that turing
machine is a natural representation for
computer programs for example when we
are writing program in some high-level
programming programming language the
sort of code that we wrote indeed can be
viewed as a clear machine because we are
not specifying how the case and the
wires are connected in a circuit
and the second and the most important
reason is that through machine can
support for any unbounded input lens and
this is very different from the circular
model because our circuit can only
support for a fixed lens input
so this leads also to the third point so
so if we consider the notion of io43
machines then both of the input program
and the obstetrical program are also
represented as a turing machine
and ideally the schedule Pro the
schedule three machine size should only
depends polynomially on the size of the
input security machine
so if Society could be much smaller than
the obscape program in the circular
model
so previously there is also a long line
for work Contracting io43 machines but
all of those Works can only support
observation for boundary input programs
and the reason is as follows to build
io43 machines they need to prove the
security of IO
so to prove the security we usually
first assume there exists some adversary
for Io and we use this adversely for Io
to build some reduction algorithm that
can break the underlying assumptions
however in the previous Works
Contracting io43 machines the reduction
algorithm runs in the two to the input
length time so here the input length is
the input length of the circuit being
obscated
so to prove the security they need to
further assume the sub-exponential
hardness of the underlying assumption so
they assume the underlying assumption is
due to the Lambda to the C hard
so here C is a constant between zero and
one and they said the security parameter
so the secret parameter Lambda is the
size of the underlying assumption
this is the description power is a large
phenomena largely enough such that this
tutorial Lambda to the C can be larger
than the running time of this reduction
algorithm
in this way they prove the security
the issue is that this also sets an
upper Bound for the input lens because
the input lens cannot be larger than the
security parameter
so why there is a due to the input lens
loose in their security reduction
so it's such a due to the input lens
loose in the security reduction inherent
or is it just a technical issue so in
fact there is a meta reduction argument
showing that this due to the input lens
flows is kind of inherent
so the observation is that
to prove the security of Io if the
anniversary always chooses two circuits
that are functionality equivalent then
the reduction algorithm should break the
underlying our solution
and on the other hand if we consider if
we switch this adversary to a fake
adversary that always chooses two
circuits that differs at some point x
star
then such a such an adversary always
exists in polynomial time because uh if
these other words knows this point x
star then he can certainly distinguish
the obscanic programs
by running the obscape program at this
point I start and observe its output so
in this case the reduction algorithm
shouldn't work
now from this argument it seems to
suggest that this reduction algorithm
must know whether the functionality
equivalence of c0 and the C1 codes so
intuitively that's why this reduction
algorithm you need to run in the due to
the input length time
and then in fact such a utility input
lens boost Source from the following
non-fast viability aspect of the
security definition of i o
so let's recall the io definition
so
we view this definition as a game
between an adversary and a Challenger
another challenge I need to check the
functionality equivalence to decide
whether the adversaries attack is
successful or not
but this tracking is inefficient because
the Challenger into enumerate all
possible input to c0 and C1 and the
check if there if they output the same
output
so we call this kind of security
definition non-force variable because of
the running time of The Challenger is
not polynomial
and this is the source of the issue
so in fact such a non-phosifiable
definition appears in many other places
in cryptography for example it also
appears in the single group systems and
sometimes you can formalize this
intuition to obtain a formal
impossibility result
so in this talk uh the question of how
to build io43 machines essentially goes
on to the following question
so how can we overcome this non-force
variability barrier
and the previously there's also another
line of work try to also try to overcome
these two to the inputer lens barrier in
the io reduction
in the i o security reduction
but all of those Works requires the
functionality equivalence of the two
circuits
to be decidable by example algorithm
so in this work we are going to depart
from the previous route
so our starting point is the following
key observation
we observe that if we want to use IO to
build some other applications
then uh
we always it seems that we always write
down a mathematical proof of
functionality equivalence for the
circuits that we are interested in
the reason is as follows so suppose we
want to use IO to build some other
applications
then in the security we need to prove
the security proof we need to prove the
security of that application
and how are we going to
uh use the io security to prove the
security of that application
so usually
we think hard to build two functions to
build two programs c0 and C1
and we write down a mathematic
mathematical proof of a functionality
equivalence for these two programs c0
and C1
only then we can apply the security of
IO to derive that the obstacles the
programs of c0 and C1 are also
indistinguishable
and from this process it seems that we
always write down such a mathematical
proof of functionality equivalence for
this two circuit c0 and C1 that we are
interested in
and furthermore I can further assume
such a proof as a very short lens in
particular
insulence must be much shorter than the
two to the input lens
because otherwise our brain cannot have
even opening cannot even have enough
time to even process it
so in this work we crucially relies on
this short mathematical proof of
functionality equivalence to bypass
this uh to the input elements lose in
the io security reduction
so what we are going to do is to
leverage this short mathematical proof
to build a very easy to build an
efficient reduction algorithm
in the security proof of IO
so by using this approach we obtain the
following result
our work to the i o for any two
terminations M1 and M2 if the
functionality equivalence of these two
three machines can be proven in cook
Theory PV and our construction is based
on the well-founded cryptographic
assumptions
what is Cook Theory PB
so PV is a formal logic system that
formalized the intuition of number 10
reasoning
and it doesn't allow a general induction
rule but without the following
polynomial time induction rule
so intuitively it says that if you can
prove that some proposition 5 equals for
n equals zero and if you can prove that
for any integer in this filing implies
Phi 2 and the five two n plus one then
you can
conclude that these five and holds for
any integer
and the Google series PV also allows the
introduction of new functional symbols
so you can introduce any polynomial time
function symbols in serial QV
so the common arithmetical operations
including addition subtraction and this
arithmetic operations can all be
introduced in this way
and also you can introduce basic logic
symbols
so what the series can Siri be prove
probability
is not that most of the polynomial
algorithms has correctness proof in
theory PV
and the most of the basic linear algebra
theorems including basic properties
about Matrix and the basic properties of
all the determinants have can be
formalized in serial PV
and also most of the common many of the
commentatorial series including kubernet
Theory and some form of the PCP Series
has proof in theory PV
in this work we further show that many
cryptographical algorithms both in this
natural categories natural algorithm
category
and we showed that the correctness of
air gamma encryption and the reactivity
encryption
and the correct and the punctual prfs
can be formalized in 0pv so punctual
functional prf is a building block in
many i o based cryptographic
applications
and we hope those examples can be served
as guidelines for you to build your own
your own applications using our results
that cannot be approvable in theory PV
indeed assuming the factoring the
fraction problem is hard
so the following series are unlikely to
be proven in serial PV the first
Assyrian are the the present theory is
the from oscillator theorem and the
second theorem is the correctness for
any
algorithms that these size Primes in
polynomial attack so both of them are
followers from the witnessing Theory
so I think this work how they will
leverage this mathematical proof of
functionality equivalence in the
security reduction of IO next I'm going
to show you a very high level overview
of our techniques
so so before uh I show you our approach
that's the first thing about water
information does a mathematical proof
provide so that means what's so special
about how mathematical proof that can
distinguish it from say let's say a
random stream
so one feature of mathematical proof is
that it has some additional structures
so the most important structure is that
it has the following local news property
so
the local news property says that each
line of the mathematic proof only
depends on constant number of previous
lines
and the inside logic system such as
propositional logic system each line of
the proof is also a circuit because each
line is from it is a Boolean formula so
it can be viewed as a circuit
so so in this talk I will use in this
talk the propositional logic we use is
the extent the flux system
and then interest of this talk I will
mainly focus on the extended Frac system
as the uh
approval of equivalence so a logic
system
uh since every proof in theory PV can be
translated to a polynomial size extended
fracture system proof
so next I will show you how to bypass
the two to the input lens barrier uh
using the extended frag proofs
the high level idea is as follows so to
prove the security of IO we are going to
use a hybrid argument
so at the two end of this hybrid
argument are those sketched programs of
c0 and all skate programs of C1
and we are going to build a series of
intermediate hybrids
and each hybrid is an obfuscation of a
circuit
and if you look at any two other
Junction circuits they are almost the
same except for very small portion of
differences
so here the difference is marked in this
green block and the red block
and the
and we can argue the equivalent
functionality equivalence of any two of
the Johnson circuits in a local way
so that means there is a polynomial time
algorithm that can decide whether the
two other jumps in the circuits are
functionality equivalent or not
in polynomial time
and this is crucial because it makes the
i o definition for viable
so in this work we build IO for locally
equivalent circuits with a loose
independent of the input lens
so here the local equivalent circuits
for the definition of a local equivalent
circuit I will show you later
so
um so in this hybrid argument for issue2
at the Johnson hybrid the security loose
is independent of the input lens
so how do we build this series of hybrid
in this work we show that if you have a
polynomial size extended flux extended
Frac proof of functionality equivalence
between c0 and C1 then you can translate
this proof to a series of intermittent
circuits where each two are jumps on the
circuits are locally equivalent
and if you have a polynomial size except
this extended drag proof then the number
of hybrids is also polynomial
so the total loss of this hybrid
argument is a polynomial times a lose
that is independent of independent of
the input lens in this way we bypass the
228 due to the inputer lens barrier
so is there any questions
so the locally equivalents are in the
locally equivalence we only care about
the difference of two items on the
circuit
and the difference of two items I think
it's very small so that's why we can
decide the functionality equivalence for
two adjunctional circuits
so I mean you
maybe you're going to say something
about this but
um you know obviously you've got an
extended fragrant proof that c0 and C1
are equivalent it's not obvious that
you've got sort of you know the the
things you're talking about are not
necessarily c0 or C1 in that they don't
look they can be completely different
circuits oh yes good question so in fact
uh in fact there is some padding going
on so when you finish a part of the c0
and C1 to sound larger circuit and we
use the and in this pattern there are
some dummy inside it so we made we made
changes to those dummy circuits
so you're keeping track basically of all
of the the circuits that show up in the
CM proof as you're going along
any questions
to uh clarify so the way you make use of
the yeah true that the segments of
intermediates with it
um
and each two adjacent circuits are
locally
yes
so
can you say anything about each step
does each step correspond to one line or
is it a more complicated so good
question so each line in fact
corresponds to one improve I watch a
little
so in the rest of this box I'm going to
be showing One technical details first I
will show you how to use a extended rack
tool to translate it to a series of
local chains uh locally equivalent
circuits the next I will show you how to
use IO for local equivalent circuits
with other moves that is
machines
so let's first focus on how to translate
this EF group to locally equivalent
circuits
so let me firstly Define what is the
local equivalence
so we say two circuits C and A C Prime
are locally equivalent if they are more
if they are almost the same with the
same topology
except for a very small size sub Circuit
of size Woburn
and we required these two sub these two
sub circuits are functionality
equivalent
so that means for aggregate other side
of these two sub circuits they are
exactly the same so in this picture the
sub circuit is marked in the green block
and the red block
and the
uh anyway allow the case within the sub
circuit to be different but it will
require these two sub circuit computes
the same function so the sub circuit are
functionality equivalent
so here the sub circuit is defined as a
induced subgraph of the entire circuit
because of the circuit we can view the
circuit as a
directed I cyclical graph so the
subsequently is just a an inducer
subgraph given a subset of dates
and these two sub circuits has the same
position in the C and zipper
the identification is given yes uh yeah
yeah the item the position of this
software
um
so uh and then in this part of the
technical receptions we are going to
show that if you have an extensive then
you can translate it to a series or for
locally equivalent circuits
so
and the the first or second in this
series of circuit in c0 and the partial
Circuit of this series of circus is on
C1 and the only two other generosity
circuits are locally equivalent
so next I'm going to take an alternative
view of this series of circuits
so I'm going to view this series of
circuits as a series of local changes
because if you view any two other jumps
on the circuit they are locally
equivalent
but uh um so it can be viewed as the so
the transition from one circuit to the
to its next circuit can be viewed as
taking a small sub circuit around the
entire circuit and replace it with some
functionality equivalent sub circuit and
we apply this series of local changes
one by one to the circular c0 so in the
end we arrive at a circular C1
so in the in the rest of this talk I'm
going to show you
uh this uh translation from the extended
drag proof to this series of local
change but for Simplicity of this talk
I'm going to ignore the topology change
for this uh series of local changes so
I'm allowed to add Advocate or dedicate
freely so this issue can be solved
by patting the gates to padding a
circuit to a larger circuit and we can
simulate the topical topological change
by changing the functionality of the
data and the for Simplicity I will also
use multi-arid case so multi-rated case
can be always simulated by the gates of
constant variety
so next I'm going to describe this
series of local changes
so so next I'm going to describe this
series of political change
in each stage there are multiple steps
so in the first stage I'm going to roll
this Circuit of C1 besides this Circle C
0.
and each time I'm going to add one date
in C1
so essentially in this stage well island
case in serial number one
the input to this second C1 is still set
to be X
in this stage
so at any step I advise for the output
of that date is never used anywhere so
into The Preserve the functionality
equivalence
so let's denote the output of c0x0 and
output of C1 as a one so at this point
the output of the entire circuit is said
to be observed
so in the next stage I'm going to grow
the proof grow the extended drug proof
slowly inside of the circuit
so suppose we have an extended product
proof of functionality equivalence
between optician c0 and C1 and the last
denotes the proof as Theta 1 to Theta l
so each acetyl is up is a line in the
proof
so at the beginning of this stage the
circuit will look like this so we have
both of c0 and C1 and the output is said
to be of zero
and in this stage I'm going to add each
step of the this stage I'm going to add
one line of the proof to the output of
the entire circuit
the output of the entire circuit is said
to be 0 and the series of C type from
Theta 1 to C to I
and the intuition behind this stage is
that each state high is also true
because it's aligned in the proof so for
any input this C5 will be evaluated to
one
then uh the output of the entire circuit
will compute o0 and there are series of
ones which is still zero so if you
preserve the functionality of the
circuits
next I'm going to show you at each step
of this stage is also preserved the
function the functionality equivalence
can be arced locally
the reason is that for the i o staff of
this in this stage
so before we add the seat high the
circuit computes c0 and a series of
theta from Theta 1 to Theta I minus 1.
and after we add C to I the circuit
computes uh C 0 over X and uh one two
six I minus one and there is an
additional seat high in the end
so the functionality equivalence can be
argued as follows so suppose the highest
line Theta I is derived by model
exponents so that means there exists
some proposition p and proposition P
implies Q somewhere in the proof another
current uh CI is a proposition queue
then we can identify the position of
this p and p in plus q and Q
so in this series of uh and
and if we look at the sub-circuit owned
by this p p implies q and Q
so before we add CT High it computes a
function on the left hand side which is
this p and the P implies q and now after
we identify it computes a function on
the right hand side and you can see the
functionality equivalence for the
circuit before I add a zip High and the
functionality under the circuit up to
where either side can be argued by only
look at this sub circuit
so we can argue the functionality
equivalence locally
so in the next stage once I have add all
the proofs in the output of the circuit
I can switch the output from o0 to o1
and the intuition behind this stage is
that if we look at the last line Theta L
it must be a proposition saying uh the
output of all zero is the same as output
over
uh
61. so if you look at the sub circuit
formed by uh o0 and the C file then
before this switching it computes a
function on the left hand side and after
we do this switching into computer
function computes our function on the
right hand side
so the functionality equivalence of this
solution step can also be argued in a
local way
and the next uh once I switch the output
of the entire circuit to use o1 I can
shrink is proof so I can delete each
line of the proof one by one in the
reverse order that I add them so in the
end of at the end of this stage I can
delete all the proofs and obtain a
circuit that I have both c0 and C1
Hardware
and the output of the entire circuit is
now set to be C1 and set to be o1
so the functionality equivalence can
also be argued in a local way similar to
the growing approved stage
finally
so now
finally the Circuit look like this so we
have both c0 and C1 and the output of
the circuit is set to be over
part of the in other at the beginning of
this stage the output of zero is never
used anywhere so we can delete them what
in the reverse
tubercultural order
so at the end of this stage we arrive at
this circular C1
so this uh now I've show you how to
translate from c0 to C1 using a series
of local changes
and the functionality equivalence at
this stage can also be argued in a
similar way as people
any questions
yeah
[Music]
because I understood when you got rid of
low zero that was that was good and I
think I see how you will get induction
on my Theta L minus one because the
children in C1 also need to behave
correctly can you say
so it's a it's a reverse so essentially
we are reversing the procedure that we
add those proofs
so the only difference is that the first
proposition now becomes over instead of
all zero but it doesn't affect this
procedure
because when you add a when you add a
CLI it only depends on other Theta but
not all zero
the first part everything is
symmetric
so next I'm going to show you how to
build IO for locally prevalent circuits
with all the rules that is the
exponential in input elements yep
topology of the circuit but in the
reality I cannot change the topology
because of the this IO Construction
so if we use extensive drive then we can
always show them and show them the size
of each other
so
um so our idea our initial idea is to
build this observation using a git
package obscation template using a new
bit by grade application template and
the idea is that we are going to take
each gate in the inputer circuit G and
the let is input wires denoted by L and
R and there is a output wire to node by
o
and to obscape this gate we are going to
use the io4 circuit to obscate a
circular CG so this CG will emulate the
functionality of this kg
and uh to achieve this we are going to
use some encryption algorithm and uh
authentication mechanism to assign the
wire values and the encrypt them
so the Circuit City will take the
separate text of these two input wires
as input and it will internally decrypt
those separate texts and do the
computation for this G for this great G
and output and encryption of the output
wire
so the key feature so the main advantage
of this uh eight package obscation
template is that it can preserve the
topology of the input circuit
foreign
this feature is import it's important
for us to overcome this due to the input
lens barrier in the security reduction
so let's consider two circuits C and the
C Prime that are locally equivalent and
we want to show
we want to prove this great package of
station template
let's get a package of station of them
are also indistinguishable we thought to
lose independent without the rules that
is that is exponential then you put the
lens
so how do we argue this so we first
leverage this topological preserving
property so we can identify water is the
position of the of stated sub circuit in
the obstacles program
and the since and note that each gate
outside of these two sub circuits are
exactly the same in C and C Prime so the
get a package of station of them are
also identically distributed so we can
simply ignore them
an owning focus on notification of these
two sub circuits
and the QR code the observation of these
two sub-circuits are indistinguishable
we can use a reduction that has loose
due to the input lens loose
due to the input the lens to this sub
circuit and since the size of this
subject is very small we can bypass the
2 to the impolence barrier
any questions
where the order login comes in like
this
uh
good question so
um
uh so
so because of because of the size of the
sub circuit is the order of Logan so
this in this step the security loose is
at least a two to the Logan so which is
our predominant
any further questions
right uh yes so so the in fact the input
size of CG May depends on the security
parameter but it's independent of the
input lens because the influence could
be much larger than the screen parameter
so
um but this idea doesn't work directly
because of the following mix and match
attack so
people are so considered following
adversary that you can observed of
schedule program
so the adversary can run this obscape
program for two different input X and
extra and you can record the
intermittent server attacks of these two
exclusion
and now the adversary can mix while the
left uh separate text for one of the
execution and mix it with the separate
text of the other execution
so now the schedule page will reveal
more information than to shoot you
because normally if we run this program
only study then uh so for some
combination of the input combinations
this is created before it's a great will
never be excluded
so intuitively this Associated this
anniversary can force this official date
to reveal more information than to shoot
you so we cannot prove his security
so our next idea is that we are going to
modify this circuits CG to have it pick
the entire input to the inputer Circuit
as the input
I need to internally check the
consistency between
it will internally check the consistency
about the user separate text with
respect to the input
the issue is this with this approach is
that the size of the input lens is too
long because we can only we're only
allowed to use io4 small size circuits
so to fix this our idea is to replace
this input with the wires that this G
depends on
because in some setting this gate key
may not depend on the entire input for
example if the depth of this circuit is
very shallow then the pth G may only
depends on constant number of inputs
so let me Define this case dependence
so for any wire in the circuit I'm going
to define the step double
consists of all the wires that W depends
on
the
and I'm going to define a capital W so
it consists of all the separate texts in
the W and here the capital sets Capital
ctw consists of is defined as a index
set so every separate text in it is
indexed by the wires
God
and now I can replace this uh input with
the capital CTR and capital CTR in the
contraction of this circuit CG so
circular CG will take the capital Ctrl
and capital CTR as input and data will
internally check the consistency
so it will eternally check this Capital
CPL and capital CTR contain the contains
the same separate text in the in the
intersection of Step L and double
but this also doesn't work directly
because for a general circuit this
Capital CTR and capital CTR may also
contains the entire input
so our next idea is to harsh Capital CPR
and capital CPR it's not hash function
and this harsh is done outside of the
construction of this circuit CG so we
hush this capital city of capacity or to
some small hash value and replace
Capital CTR and upload CTR with their
hash values in the construction of this
circuit CG
but uh we'll have another issue because
previously since we know the full
information of capital CTR and capital
CTR we can check the consistency but now
we only have access to the their hash
values so it's not clear how to check
the consistency
so our sort of idea is to apply a snark
so snark is a very short cryptographic
proof
so this is a snark well generator proof
Pi this proof will prove that there
exists a pre-image of this hash function
to this HL and HR
such that the pre-images are consistent
and the such as snark is only secure
against polynom10 adversary
so now I can modify the contraction of
CG as follows so we all have this CG
further take this proof pi as input and
it will internally check the consistency
so it will internally verified is proved
by
and then it will do the other things as
before because this disk this decryption
computes the strategy and re-encrypt the
output wire
but this also doesn't work directly
because uh to use the snarks inside of
IO we need the this statistical security
of snarks because I O security requires
the functionality equivalence and the
functionality equivalence is a
statistical requirement
so uh our final idea is to use IO
friendly snark and the key observation
here is that we in fact only care about
the consistency of a capital CTO and the
capital CTR
with the with their intersection
in their intersection with the sub
circuit
because at any time in the hybrid
argument we only change the case in this
sub circuit
so we will use some snark with
additional Summoners property called
Somewhere statistical soundness which
says that if capitals and capital CTR
and capital CTR are not consistent in
the sub-circuit then even online time
cheating adversary cannot find some
accepting proof
and we in our work we contract such as
snark from the recent work by cgg21
so here is a so finally here is a
summary of our construction of this I
over locally equivalent circuits
so for any gate in the input circuit we
are going to use io4 circuit to obscate
a circular CG which emulates the
functionality of this 8G
and the upside of this circular CG we
are going to Hash Capital CGR and
capital CTR and the generator approved
pi this proof file will approve the
consistency for these two harsh values
and this circular CG will take this hash
values and this consistently consistency
proof to ensure the consistency
so this concludes the io Construction
so finally let me show you uh how to
extend this idea to build the io
bacterial machines
so our starting point is the
propositional translation
so in Cook's original work he shows that
if you have a proof in group Theory PV
then you can translate it to your
polynomial size extend the thread proof
and in our case the PV proof is the
functionality equivalence between two
three machines M1 and M2
and given any fixed lens on
fix the input lesson we can obtain a
polynomial size extended thread proof of
functionality equivalence between C C1
and c21 so here C1 and C2 and are the
circuit that emulates the computation of
this Theory machine M1 and M2
foreign
idea is to apply this i o for locally
equivalent circuits to this circuit C1
and c21
because I O for locally equivalent
circuits allow us to bypass the due to
the input lens loose in the security
reduction once you have extended drag
proof
so
um to build io430 machine here is our
initial attempt
machine we are going to first set a
super polynomial upper bound a slightly
supercond number upper bound and zero um
so n0 is said to be a Lambda to the
logar Lambda
and the for any input element that is
responded by this n0 we are going to
convert these three machine into our
circuit that emulates the computation of
this steering machine for the input
lesson so we can obtain a series of
circuits from C1 and 2C capital and zero
and then we apply this i o for local
equivalent circuits to obtain the
schedule programs for each of those
circuits
and we put this application programs
together as the obscating the turing
machine so this is the initial idea
but this doesn't work directly because
uh if we look at the oscillator runtime
it will be at least zero which is which
is a super polynomial
so to make this obscation are efficient
we are going to Leverage The Uniform
description of this circuits from C1 to
C and zero
and the idea is that since all of those
circuits is generated by this turing
machine so there exists a very small
size circuit
that it will take the
input lens and the index I and it will
output the description of the iOS gate
in the circuit ceiling
so now we can use this small size
description circuit to generate the
observation of a ceiling
so that's the first thing we call how
did we also create the anonymous circuit
seal
so what we are going to do is uh so what
we did is uh we're going to take each
gate in the uh circular ceiling and the
use IO to obscate the gate of scatter
circular cgn from cg1 to c82 looks
therefore
and the our idea is to leverage this
uniform description circuit to generator
to generate the io obscation of this CGI
so this leads to the following efficient
contraction of I O featuring machine so
given Authority machine we first build
some uniform version of this circular CG
under this uniform version of circular
CG will take a input element and an
index I so the index I is well specified
uh what is a interval specifier gate in
the circular season
and it also takes the input uh the also
take the same input as the
circular CG CG
so this uniform circuit will internally
compute the description of the iOS gate
of CN and do everything this CG need to
do
and we just use io4 circuit to offskate
this circular you see
to obtain a skated program for three
machines
any questions
so uh finally let me summarize the
result and the discussion on future
directions
so in this work we establish our
correspondence between the inference
rules of a logic system to prove the
functionality equivalence of two
programs
and the techniques that allow us to
argue the indistinguishability for Io
and for the logic system we consider the
extended product was Cooks Theory PV
and the corresponding techniques we
developed are the i o for local
equivalent circuits
so
the one future interaction is to
consider how to extend this idea to
achieve io40 machines with functionality
equivalence proven in approval in JFC
and the question is how to deal with the
how to develop the corresponding proof
techniques to deal with the inference
rules in CFC
and as a week ago we can also consider
other logic systems in Bonita
arithmetics
[Applause]
questions
it's a general question you get the
local office station
how General is that can you you could
have two circuits to do the same thing
very different from each other can I
always see
industry
yeah I think so for the carbon
techniques I think of the local
equivalence can also been proven
extended threat because
but maybe there's some way to for
example generalize this get a package of
scheduling to some during Machine by
three machine application
muscles
just like